hello and welcome to see your plantation
basically a blue water do we have a name
nope so we goes for the b6 defense to
the English opening sometimes called the
English Defence which is kind of funny
that we have an English Defence to the
English opening but yeah that's what it
is c5 that's a decent line for black
okay did not play a quick d 5 which I
expect to to happen usually just its
content with the situation so I'm happy
to expand at five oh wow so really I
Bishop takes is also quite good but
Knight takes a 95 seems fine so how to
play this is a really nice position here
maybe just play on the e-file
not sure a g6 now he has to go g6 I can
push the H porn even further up the
board I'm not sure if it does that much
i owe probably probably yes
it will be difficult femdom to play this
with the with those pawns and yeah near
the king very very difficult check
97 and rookie seven are both already on
what and now I go rookie seven well well
well well 97 king of age I know that I
was briefly thinking I can take here
I'll wait if I go Bishop g5 if I go
Bishop g5 we can do queen d 5 49 f 3 oh
wow okay so i actually have to have to
take the Queen and then that is not that
brilliant actually this is not as great
as it should have been yeah now I I got
enough gone to the loudness just just
reading the Queen for peace and and
rookie is a bit it's not enough that was
worse even for him mmm ok so what to do
here before night a for net will come to
see three probably
okay let's play some some strengthening
moves I can play 94 may be okay
yeah it should be it should still be
fairly easy he has a bishop on g7 on h8
that it's not doing anything at all
no no it's its fatty its fatty easy
I don't enter that easily hmm i was a
bit stupid could have gone there
immediately
should be fun than taking the idea
and just need to enter the moment i
enter i win the win everything here
maybe I could have played Quincy for
even oh that's creative it's a creative
idea hmm
this is probably easier if I just takes
you five is cesium
yeah should we should cannot move time
warning check
hmm okay black resigns yeah I don't they
I have to f5 I think like it's basically
lost that that looks too bad disposition
when I was happy to gain all that space
f5 that looks extremely weakening rook
takes is given as still okay by the
computer whoa what's the deal okay that
the engine gives up the exchange he and
says that this is still kind of okay hmm
yeah it's not great um dad this looks
pretty awful maybe you can argue about
93 if I if I need to do that but if i
get to age 6 this is more or less win
because yeah he's playing with this yeah
yeah lucky 7 yeah it does win it does
when I was a little bit in doubt but
maybe something better it it's it's
perfectly it's perfectly okay yeah he
probably should retreat the night and
after after he gets this completely
trapped the engine gives this now is a
strong strong move yes'm something like
that black falls apart ok I played in a
slower technical way but it's also I
think Jenna trade this and now I just
have to get into the position which is
accomplished by putting the bishop on
before taking here and then white enter
so that is a fairly clear way to win
this is this kind of structure is
something to remember if you get to get
this is really extremely favorable
because I mean even the bishops trap but
it's also very favorable and others
circumstance because the age seven point
is so weak and the black king is always
boxed in so in many end games rook
ending a green ending this is will be
very very problematic for black to
defend SH seven points such a problem ok
guys thanks for watching